c'est non non quoi de plus bouleversant
qu'une paimpolaise papa me polèse
bigoudène quoi de plus bouleversant
qu'une paimpolaise dévorer d'angoise
guettant le retour de son marin si ce
n'est deux paimpolaise dévorer d'angoise
guettant le retour de leurs marins ça
pour ce qui est de l'angoisser on peut
dire que je suis dévorer certes rien ne
lui rendra son cher mari qui gît
désormais par 3000 mètres de fond avec
un poulpe sur la tête et un harpon dans
l'oeil mais il serait cruel de la [ __ ]
à l'eau pour autant car la bougresse
peut encore servir
je peux encore servir à quoi dire et
vous regardez bien
[Musique]
etonnant non
c'est non non
[Musique]